this morning our ongoing series america
the beautiful' focus is on Utah where
the mountains are best known as ski
destinations but in the winter at
Canyonlands in arches national park you
can find an escape from the crowds that
fill those parks when it gets warmer
Jeff Glor recently went there to see how
park officials are leading a program to
restore the ancient landscape they look
like strangers who've been here for 65
million years
red rises in the desert that accepts
sunlight in mind-bending ways you can
see any shape you want though it's hard
not to see one of the most beautiful
places on earth what is it about the
desert for me it's always been the
wide-open spaces you know you're very
small and so therefore any problems that
you might have also feel really small
and so it's really a place to put things
in perspective
it's restorative I think though this is
an invasive annual grass but there are
times when even the desert needs to be
restored the epic arches and cliffs
haven't gone anywhere but after more
than a century of cattle trampling
beginning in the mid 1800s vast
stretches of land in the West still
haven't come back native grass doesn't
grow when wildlife can't survive which
is why Canyonlands and arches national
parks were involved in an innovative
program using something called con mods
when somebody first hears con my really
random what is that right
it's short for connectivity modifier it
doesn't exactly roll off the tongue it
doesn't what it's important yeah it's
kind of a catchy term con mod the main
reason why they were called that is they
they modify the connectivity or they
break up the connectivity of these
really big bear ground areas of our
grasslands that have not recovered from
past uses it's a big idea with lots of
little parts the x-shaped con mods catch
seeds and moisture creating tiny islands
of recovery that multiply over and over
so we're in Salt Valley now one of the
areas that's really in need of
restoration by having these islands of
recovery out here on the landscape we're
able to get perennial grass established
into these systems again so far
scientists here say con mods have a 90
percent six
rates this area is going that direction
on its own
we got an up-close look at the program
during the slow season here one of the
best times to visit what is it about
this place in wintertime I think the
winter everything slows down and I you
can almost feel or hear the rocks taking
a deep breath and there's a sense of
solitude and stillness that it's pretty
special
Alison Vaughn lung Kaizen has been a
ranger at Arches since 2012 I felt a
connection to this place that every time
I left I came back and it feels like
home this park is home to more than
2,000 natural stone gateways including
the world-famous delicate arch all
formed by a relentless and timeless
exercise of erosion it moves slowly even
though the turnstiles don't attendance
at arches has gone from about 2,500
people in 1940 to nearly 1.5 million
today getting a look and listen to the
park at moments like this is rare you
can hear the birds singing right now we
can hear them you know on a busy day and
spring or summer or fall there'd be a
lot of voices here yeah just listen
like I said you wouldn't hear that at
other times of the year sitting in this
job it seems like the National Park
Service is best kept secret
for CBS this morning Jeff Glor Arches
National Park in Utah this has just been
such a great series to say I need to go
it looks like we had fun doing yeah for
sure and the bird hit its cue well done
was on bird